The correct answer here is O(n²),
and to see that, we just have to look at how many time steps of this
I wouldn't requires other function within.
As you remember, this line up here takes zero times steps
because it's just a memory access and we said those were free.
This one here, it depends again what you do with the end of the range here
but it's going to be executed about n times, so it's either n or n + 1.
That doesn't really make much difference here because now we can use big O notation.
How often is this inner loop here executed?
The first time, it's actually executed n times,
then the next time it's executed, it's going to be executed on the n - 1 times,
and so on and so on because this i here, this value here increases,
and as this increases, this inner loop here is going to be executed less and less times.
Here we have first time, we're going to have n times steps,
the next time, we're going to have n - 1 times steps,
the next time, we're going to have n - 2 times steps and so on,
and the same basically also holds true for this inner loop here.
So, if this is executed n times, then the inner loop here,
again depending on how you count that is going to be executed n times or n - 1 times
So, these two parts here, that is exactly where you need the hit.
So, it's two times this part here, so it's two times n² + n over 2.
So, the total here is n² + n.
So, the total number of times steps is 0 + n + n² + n which is n² + 2n which is O(n²).
Now, as you get more familiar with analyzing algorithms,
you will actually see that having two inner loops usually leads with quadratic running time
and you wouldn't even have needed this extracted here.
So, with more practice, the analysis of algorithms becomes easier and easier
and you will have to do less and less of the tedious single line counting.
One final thing, of course, O(n³) is technically correct
but as I already mentioned when discussing big O notation,
you want to bound  to be as tight as possible.
This is really the only correct solution.